بحسب الجانب الامريكي البنتاجون وايضا
البيت الابيض هناك تطور وصفته القياده
الامريكيه بانه خطير وبانها ستعمل على
محاسبه من يقف وراء هذا الهجوم ما الذي
جرى اليوم ما نعرفه من معلومات ان هناك
منطقه حدوديه مثلث حدودي بين العراق
وسوريا والاردن يحتوي على مجموعه من
القواعد العسكريه من من الدول الثلاث يعني
من الجانب العراقي هناك قواعد عسكريه من
الجانب الاردني وايضا من الجانب السوري ال
المعلومات ليست مكتمله وهناك اكثر من
روايه لما جرى كل بحسب الدوله التي تحدثت
سنبدا بما قالته الولايات المتحده
الولايات المتحده قالت ان طائره مسيره
هاجمت احدى القواعد العسكريه الامريكيه
وهذه القاعده العسكريه بحسب البنتاغون
وبحسب البيت الابيض تقع داخل الاراضي
الاردنيه
وبانها تسمى تي 23 او تاور 23 اي البرج 23
الجانب الامريكي يقول بانها قاعده صغيره
عند الحدود شمال شرق الاردن تتمركز فيها
القوات الامريكيه وتقول وزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه بان هذا الهجوم ادى الى مقتل
ثلاثه جنود على الاقل واصابه 24 جنديا اخر
اصابه عدد منهم خطيره وبالتالي العدد قد
يكون مرشح للارتفاع هذه هي او هذا هو
الموقع التقريبي بحسب ما قالت وزاره
الدفاع الامريكيه وبحسب ما قال البيت
الابيض الرئيس بايدن تحدث وتناول الموضوع
قال ان الولايات المتحده ستلاحق من قام
بتنفيذ هذه العمليه واستهداف ال نقطه
التموضع الامريكيه ومقتل وما ادى الى مقتل
واصابه الجنود الامريكيين هذا ما قاله
الرئيس الامريكي اما الجانب الاردني فمصدر
حكومي اردني قال ان الهجوم لم يقع داخل
الاراضي الاردنيه قال ان الهجوم وقع داخل
الاراضي السوريه عند نقطه قريبه جدا من
الحدود مع الاردن عند المكان نفسه اي عند
المثلث الحدودي الذي يجمع بين العراق او
نقطه التقاء الحدود العراقيه الاردنيه
السوريه المصدر الاردني تحدث المصدر
الحكومي الاردني وبالتالي هو مصدر رسمي
قال ان الهجوم وقع داخل الاراضي السوريه
والقى باللوم على من وصفها بالجماعات
الارهابيه المتطرفه قال انها من نفذت هذا
الهجوم حتى الان لم نسمع اي رد فعل من
بغداد من الجانب العراقي حول ما جرى اذا
نحن ازاء ما يصفه محللون عسكريون بانه
تطور خطير لانها المره الاولى التي يتم
فيها
استهداف جنود امريكيين او قاعده تتبع
للجيش الامريكي منذ بدء الحرب الاسرائيليه
على قطاع غزه ونحن امام موقع جغرافي غير
واضح بالكامل الجانب الامريكي يقول انه
الى داخل الاراضي الاردنيه قرب الحدود اما
الجانب الاردني يقول ان الاستهداف تم داخل
الاراضي السوريه كل هذه الامور بطبيعه
الحال ايمان ستتبلور اكثر وسيكون لدينا
المزيد من المعلومات نتابعها معك